What I'm going to be talking about
tonight is the optimistic view,
which I take of the future of economic
future of this country in the world.
I don't think innovation is exhausted by
any means.
I'm not sure how he would know what the
future of innovation is,
but I don't think it's exhausted.
But I,
but I,
I think my main point is that the world
is,
is developing.
The whole world is becoming richer.
We are in a period of the fastest world
growth and income per head in history.
And when China and India and sub Saharan
Africa and Latin America come online,
we're going to have in the next 50 or a
hundred years a world cultural,
economic.
It can,
um,
uh,
sports,
intellectual explosion such as you have
never seen.